you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease i'm here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it now
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bat radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of me
who wants to hunt
and consume blood
can you control it
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
the other half wants to control you hey
uh dr mike you and i should stay in
touch
not doing anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
[Music]